what's a fool what's up fool podcast
what's up fool podcast we should we have
balance ball everywhere mom booster
absolutely cowbell cowbell more cowbell
no more cows and bells hey we got
business already from whether they're a
sports ESPN and HBO late at night boxing
thank you and you scared me when you did
the everybody wishes and caviar dreams
no chocolate where dreams if not it's
okay it was way different when I met you
guys at Dodger Stadium top deck a little
corner yeah that was cool Oh speakin and
I was so bad at sneaking in it was good
though you would have to sneak in we
just should have told them I told them
everything at the gear which was dumb
then did you buy a sweater Dodger
sweater I remember maybe like three four
years ago you're fertile see cognition
yeah we sat down good you know but you
know what
elet how Elinor felt you said how Elinor
felt when you ran into dice and her she
cut the line well how she felt she said
she felt like she just you know hit a
puppy or whatever she said she felt
awful for you being in line every time
like my my boarding pass day is our
primary goal Ruby oh I can get it behind
with our first class but even though I'm
not going first class my C's way in the
back but I get to go with them so
anybody traveler when we can come with
me
or take a risk to come with me so she
was like boarding Eleanor for the Comedy
Store podcast she was boarding number
six last group six her seated by the
restroom you're gonna see say a lot of
horror where you have to check your bag
take my cane Ellen oh yeah so well ago
Gary I told ya okay
come with us she opens her tonight I
told her come with us I'm afraid
so she came with us that she got in she
was wow man I feel like I got a way
where was I I just chopped jumping in
with in the boarding pass those our
biggest cry right so great look we're
hanging out fool like we see this
old-ass fool dog like very old here like
so we see the two then okay he's too
late anyway like some shish chance right
have you guys had a muscle shirt - yeah
black tank top and way too long shorts
you know like like a cholo we're devil
Dickies let those cholos were to go to
the gym with the White Sox all the way
up
yeah man exactly but he had low saggy
dog yeah oh yeah low sauce was Shambo he
literally he was Jeff ready for a rave
what's a little hiking boots my hand up
it was a dice paper oh no he was what he
was Eleanor we were you know me bro I
don't care Michelle shocked so I get
starstruck I told that Lester what's up
guys man man we saw you in before you
need vent right now all right now you'd
know something right now I'm the Sabbath
so I said what's up dice bag who stopped
me well gee we just saw you at the man
we're probably at elevation and if we
are about our being Barnaby and I looked
at her like no she he looked at her like
who are these guys - I know they're I'm
gonna go look for neck pillows okay I'll
beat me I'm gonna for neck pillows she
said another neck pillow so this book
comes back and the bed you guys play the
dice man he's like hiding over
by the by the magazines or you don't
wanna get recognized by us again but
this food passes by what do you say
though you got it out dice dices
complete excitement unbelievable dude it
[ __ ] shook the [ __ ] air polluted
who yell so loud I laugh so hard like
I'm gonna floor a wood laughing this
black full of working information came
out through the wheelchair so you are
right now you wanna put me in a
wheelchair broke people and then I seen
the diced mango you know what Ella no
that's what I get for being famous that
lunatics yelling my name you don't know
her no not personally I met him a couple
times
so do we see the hughley's show what was
his um
it had her you know some guy that works
with him a Mexican Navy SEAL hugely has
a Mexican Navy SEAL so but he was a good
guy he was cool cause [ __ ] so Joey were
telling you a hugely a bow tie oh yeah
we just have a dice man over there but
he wants a go ahead you know we're just
talking about dice man so therefore
round to do my arrow 3 go [ __ ] I
couldn't believe it he goes Oh
first of all first of all nobody knows
who the [ __ ] Johnny Rock he is right
just hanging out just with us right by
the way trying to rock the other podcast
with [ __ ] uh Nick Garrett make it
right hashtag nobody knows who the book
Johnny rookie is I say that [ __ ] so wait
he like he introduced himself to Elinor
like this hey you want a edible now he
has edible candies
that birds I don't know creep walks up
and says to somebody at the airport you
want uh you wanna uh one of the [ __ ]
both candies car the ones that are very
mushy taffy a caramel camera they're
like starburst they're like a little
beer jelly Bieber's going become in your
pocket the last one sweaty that's like
the end of Ferris Bueller when Jeffrey
Jones the principal sits down of that
girl and she says you want a gummy worm
yes also I do sit around to watch it
he's our Idol bro anyway so do I
remember I woke up to you swallow slow
he never turns around never ever
he's like motionless brilliant I
throwing arrows like you guys material
so I fine so this dude Raji go it's out
of April artist our pages right now I
don't speak no you're not what's your
real name
Andrew clay silverstein that's his name
best thing to come out of Brooklyn
chocolate so hopeful walk it off sleepy
brother neck pain hired dog big ass
accountant colors like the ones you get
when you get got como o jewelry in the
whole general word at the end of casino
like Frank Rothstein Frank Rothstein
so pretty blush I try to cut my ties
here but so disappear with the walls I
don't know when he was starting in I
think he page his name in front of him
no no you did it
so I'm dude I'm standing in line to
check my bag get a free bag check and
then there's three people in front of me
so I go yeah can you pay your friend
tell him to meet his friends out of gate
c12 what's his name Andrew clay
silverstein Andrew Klay silverstein
please come to the gate c12 and meet
your friends they're waiting for you Shh
it goes twice dude
sounds odd dude let me check my bag I
forgot you know I'm excited
well I start checking my bag I don't
know what's going on this is important I
saw was my passport and you I got you
ideally no no no this this is big what
you put in my bags supposedly the dice
man he likes to play gags on people
right I'm a goofball right not today
Doug oh I give my [ __ ] take off [ __ ]
I go there by Felipe dog [ __ ] die and
I know he wants nothing to do with you
right now you didn't know I know with
you guys you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] up big time you [ __ ] up big
time
and he's off you don't you started
alright you're gonna kick ass Eddie
Griffin you're gonna get it okay you're
not gonna get it today but one day
you're gonna get it I'm out who got it
today doc alright
I raised poppin off at the mouth are you
doing deal you want to be on my podcast
I hope the mob dog yeah so no missing
link
so now DL visit man those are laughing
with mr. Andrew Dice clays personality
and the meter changed after they they
[ __ ] made a pit of chicken is after
yeah you know you get your pants pulled
down your Trump's in front of everybody
then you put them up everybody laughs
Algie go back to your friends and you
know you're gonna get somebody oh yeah
junior high
see what plotting what can he do
man to look strong but he goes yes oh
yeah he was cool he got got yeah but
nobody mess no nobody does he doesn't
gagging so he talks to deal on a repo
okay beekeeper thanks man he pitcher
there's somebody what time we saw him
remember he had all the comedian they
were from his era mess with robbery
Obadiah and they put other chairs
together yeah so he came for the stage
[ __ ] face things so and then I get in
I get on the plane I passively pin in
that dice man in the corner I was never
happier in the world who are these guys
so that's his name silverstein Andrew
clay Silverstein's they actually named
after the president Andrew clay he was
performing a casino tulsa in tulsa lane
and and DL Hughley had dinner cuz a
casino too buddy even one of the hell
gates he said we there's no flight going
there so here to one drive on two hours
to the game
deep in Louisiana yeah but the red was
so bright I'm working the Canelo triple
G fight will be there that week so I'm
working for a goal I work for Golden Boy
and I'm gonna be doing the online
broadcast so like if you're watching at
home you can watch Jim Lampley in Mexico
remember watching them but they also
have now where you can buy the
pay-per-view for your phone if you're a
keeps me on our wedding whatever instead
of getting the illegal bootleg streams
you can now get a legit stream that's
not going to break down and I'll be the
voice of that
so everybody know it for these [ __ ]
pay-per-view fight but I'll show you
people buy popcorn it's pretty much
that's crazy you're gonna I'm trying to
get you there on Friday for the weigh-in
because you're gonna be at the Hard Rock
Friday night Mira laughter everybody get
the heavy weights up there guard a
pay-per-view there's gonna be four of a
total card there's eight we started
three o'clock so clock is the first
fight yeah but yeah they have one you
take a little break usually that time
the only people they're mean that's how
people get so drunk they say it's crazy
I wish you actually go to cycle I know
you're in Laughlin that night but uh
Friday for the wind it's really cool
it's first-come first-serve at the MGM
in the Grand Arena and shows up early
because the lines come first serve so
there's no for the William all the way
in the way it used to be just hard
are there bets placed on the way in the
crowd in the crowd in the crowd there's
no official bets there's lots of bets
beam a side if the guy touch you they go
together yeah there's all yeah I've
heard people in the crowd because you
have nothing to do there so like you
could get really close and so people
line up early and there's beer be it's
Vegas being sold all day long so you get
there and it's a party there's my dad
she's gone so it's really festive but if
you guys come with me would be cool and
hanging out in the back and you can see
what's going on and then as soon as they
get off the scale all interview I think
Gennady I get him
I get the b-side so I'll be on the scale
interview them and then everybody booing
and people going on after the skill or
what are the weight for triple G they
find out 161 say it says pretty good so
they have to be at 160 if they go over
they have to give two hours to lose
whatever it is a couple answers after
they already sucked up dry as it is
after the 160 that night they probably
eat a lot huh what well they were you
again at the fight e for this one I
don't think so for some sanctioning Bell
still have it where you can only wait no
more than 10 pounds for this one it's
fine but these guys you don't want to go
too heavy they usually weigh about 170
to 175 that's a fight yeah at the fight
what they do is they go they'll
rehydrate you'll see a lot of electoral
eat you know people call it Pedialyte
but it's if you
Canelo had literally where there the
real one the one for Mexico electrolyte
literally so that'll be legit Alicia's
yeah they hit that right away then they
go have like a pasta dinner and like
they don't go in like McDonald's rings
like that they have like nutrition is
that given the properties that Boxster
boom boom Mancini yeah yeah handsome
member Philadelphia that fool barely
made away in brought in for wonder if
fighting with a middleweight fight
walter word fight and assumed he was so
happy could that for starving as soon as
he got off the beam that foot started
eating a big ol Philadelphia cheesesteak
bro yeah which is the worst thing to do
with technology now nutritionist and
dies they do with the better way than
the way in the past before used to be
let's not eat for the week and then go
stand in the Sun and move away and like
don't drink any water
I knew wrestlers who had spit in the
trashcan in high school to make weight
spit it's like that's enough because to
change their way you'll see before the
weigh-in guys are always chewing gum cuz
they're gonna spin it a lot because
these guys have like probably 5% body
fat at this point and it's all waterways
a lot of it so yeah so if you miss
weight you have to pay usually 20% to
the Commission yeah it's no joking you
know you're making a million you got
paid two hundred most visible do you
have to throw out to lose some weight
Rodrigo can make heavy weight because
there's no yeah say holy fear was 235
huh she actually is to fight smaller
than that he's the felt like at 215 220
but he was all jacked up rocked up so
you could have a huge disparity within a
heavyweight champ number Butterbean the
big guy was like almost 400 pounds jeans
wasn't a book and he did fight a 250
yeah have you once you're a heavyweight
it doesn't matter it's smaller divisions
what's the lowest flyweight yeah most
guys like their 106 Wow Jackie yeah 105
yeah usually those are the TIE fighters
I forgot what happened I put the beans
in Vietnam yeah those guys I haven't
seen 105 7th grade did you see the
smallest I've worked usually it's like
112 and then there's a couple 115 it's
mostly guys like between 126 to 140
I lumber and I've got to they have pen
wait pen wait wait wait all right yeah
it'll be good though you should go if
you go be behind the stage who do you
got I took man it's tough like the 2478
on each gate okay don't like each other
cantock was really affect with steroids
in Mexico yeah the clenbuterol it's
contaminated
so what really happened on the story
goes the corner Canelo then he doesn't
know what he ate that he had some meat
with all these high-tech nutrition but
think about it if you go to a restaurant
street tacos like okay if you're at home
and you go and you bring your own food
then you're like you know where you
getting it from right if you're getting
the grass-fed if you're going to Whole
Foods in your trust but if you're going
to a restaurant you don't know which cow
came from there right so like could he
have done it possibly could he be
cleaned possibly but so has a little
asterisk that's the that's what Gennady
golovkin is going off about how you know
he failed the test twice and it was in a
system so it's a lot of back and forth
they don't like each other that's the
good thing
whoo Gennady and trip with me and Canelo
they don't like each other so that's why
it's gonna be good and then the thing is
Canelo has a lot of haters that are
Mexicans yeah they love that fault but
you but here's the thing though I
figured it out the Mexican fans I hate
Canelo are just usually those Mexicans
that just hate everything just to hate
the hater Mexicans oh let me go against
this guy no matter what another boy I
like the large like those kind of guys
oh he's not funny oh yeah yeah just to
be a dick yeah or just to go contrarian
kind of react to other stuff oh yeah
they'll react no matter where like
there's like no Mexicans for golovkin
shirts like a front of my Sal made the
shirts Mexicans for Olivia fool you were
just making it just to sell it and all
of a sudden his shirts got bootleg by a
legit store in Vegas and they took was
making sloppy shirts was so full Amanda
I'd love to bet you man I'm gonna be at
the east on a parade wire yeah man I'm
gonna be the Grand Marshal no you're not
no you're not Graham I don't know if
you're a Grand Marshall bit of honor at
honoree
you're an honoree ain't going
[Laughter]
that's Sunday September 16th caller dog
well somebody from I think J in our
upholstery that guy that you went to
skid row with the lowriders who passed
out you have some stuff it's good rope
one of those guys is going to drive it
Mexican Independence Day
he's an honoree he was supposed to be
grand marshal but I don't know I think
was a timing thing come on yeah Danny
Trejo maybe same fools they used to hate
a la jolla because he was in a real mix
up because he's all good-looking had all
the women got the grand marshal cool
Akula con with a rat squeak squeak mean
anyway anyways what's up fool what
happened a Ben Affleck this way boys
still crying just fall off the wagon
right yeah but bad no it's a year and a
half ago he was he was dating this woman
who was a producer from SNL for the last
year and then yeah she's a producer and
then she broke it off with him because I
think he was already going down that
spiral right he was starting to drink
again and it was affecting their
relationship then after she breaks up
with him like immediately he goes out
with some playboy model right but this
isn't like I think she's I think she saw
stars in her eyes like I think she saw
stars in her eyes like I'm gonna yeah
I'm gonna be the new chick on the side
you know on his arm though I think she
thought she was gonna be the chicken
flavor I'm not on the side but the new
one yeah yeah but she was just like it
was just like one of those leaving Las
Vegas situations where she was just
hanging out drinking with him for a few
days maybe he was on a bender
bro he was one of those benches bro like
what your happy dog I'm saying okay they
have a photo of him a jack-in-the-box
with her like smile and ordering he's
all hi you could see he's ready
I love saliva
only Alex get on the side a little
[ __ ] popping yes a penis you know
when you've been in a good one I mean up
for three days yeah I use on this is
temporary hi where you could tell he's
gonna crash you look good with a
beautiful girl like 22 she likes she
know the children know who what been
after going through but yeah so then the
next but so then I was like three or
four days of that I've been coked out
and I've been an addict and I've been
that [ __ ] that messed up without a
pretty sure what he was telling her bro
I think you could be good bad girl bad
girl probably lying star but yeah so the
last then the last thing is so after
three or four days of them partying
together and her staying at his house
first night they went out they went to
Nobu or oh my god nice the second one
was jacket so you know they just have
boiler room yeah so anyway the third or
fourth day Jen Jennifer Garner you want
to meet Matt Damon víctor muñoz oh they
cut their pool party got the readers to
you know before bill
what did Jenny gardeners so Jennifer
Gardner associate Jennifer Gardner was
caught like four days after his binge
started she's at the house and she's
caught walking out like like freaking
out and like shaking and crying right
cuz she saw him in there I guess and she
comes back like half an hour later with
some other woman and they take him and
that the TMC is all over them the whole
time so as they take him Jennifer's got
sunglasses on the front this woman
sitting next to her in the front they
stopped at jack-in-the-box again I think
this is just throwing food down his
throat before they take him to rehab see
they were on the way to rehab she's
taking him to rehab this ex-wife
everybody listen out live look up Ben
Affleck jack-in-the-box a second time
there he's in the back and he is
sweating sweating and crying his face is
puffy he's a mess so she must have
walked in on that gardeners who he has a
child with right two to three children
Oh
all in all under five years old and so
she's she's sitting there like this at
the drive-thru yeah I would I've been
through this [ __ ] before like I'm yeah
somebody who's been there a codependent
who's seen you go through in and out and
and she's done she's like she's done at
this point I mean pretty much helping
you it's a good rehab that's it she just
cares enough for you so you don't die so
she doesn't have to explain it to the
kids you know what I mean like that's
but she cares enough about you through
the kids that she's helping you out but
it is so sad you could see it like she's
just done in her face you need some
Tiger blood man that's a good dougie
boys dog so anyway yeah today this is
our funnier bad what's up was that first
day you learners but you understand man
like you don't know man like have you
been there when you're coming down it's
the worst because at first you're all
happy bro and with your homies your
friends
but then everybody has to go to the
regular lives grow eventually hopefully
your left nobody right they gonna walk
the dogs cool people little people get
luck or people around you start getting
locked up they're gonna they gonna
shoplift or whatever oh whatever they
get old at the end that's what been
after was going through he know that he
knows that listen once you get the
hamburger it's the end it'll be at the
end of the rainbow road he went back to
darkness
yeah and darkness my old friend yeah and
those people who are partying with them
have no idea this is his what is this
another level of party in there not it's
not partying and then party yeah Ben
Affleck sell your motorcycle Ben Affleck
if he's not ready to recover which I'm
pretty sharply buddy not ready the first
thing that he's gonna happen through his
head when you sober up on the second day
when it's taking this over that's when
you start to get a passion I go back to
party I beat this you know I'm not
crying on the second day a second yeah
but it's still in your brain no you
don't realize that you think you're just
friends
cold cold PCP whatever it's in you but
your brain is there looking for my
problem like even though I cry like that
jacket about school nobody goes there
sober I know so after I'm sobering up
and I'm hearing like other addicts
stories I'm thinking about and I'm
thinking she said with a crackhead but
do we be doing crack 20 15 years a
bullet doing I've already been doing
crack crack three years right I'm
thinking oh man I got smoked crack
better with me maybe the wrong this time
and what you were thinking also is there
much to go back and do it right this
time
right it was dunno you'd almost crack I
waste as you go back earned it I'm back
doing the exactly the way this addict
told me this time I knew I got a medal a
metal a metal hanger to push my family
upon a brillo pad and I was doing it
better and it's like every time I
stopped a wimp I learned how to be a
better drug addict when you go to rehab
you learn that oh yeah about techniques
in the green well don't you know
school like UCLA Extension they're
helping you out a little growing your
hearing story about addicts but she's
the older water they tell you like oh
now homie your way to the crack gonna
push it to the other side I don't know
after my after my pad was to stuff
though I threw it away bro waster yo man
so that's what you go through we know
like when you start so green dough you
also sent a fight through it
you also said that Ben was probably
thinking the whole time
damn I didn't really go out with a bang
yes like I didn't have a big enough
ohm before I have to go to rehab or
marriage is done after wobble when you
have when you take someone into a rehab
sober yeah he'll be like oh like they
didn't get a chance to get all of it out
of their system I wanted to go out there
try to kill myself again ha ha Twitter
is Durant Sports Instagram Bethel vision
living the dream podcast which you've
been on and the reason I started is
because Lisa told me how to do it so
thank you guys so what we're doing it
and I keep doing it and but yeah my
podcast your own little tribe in your
own fan I have so much that I've
expanded and I went on Marty Mourinho's
nice
no you are I'm not ready I'm not ready
you know how you know you have a good
ear page and I listen to your Twitter's
I know you know you have fans and when
your fans get off you and fight each
other or they want to like design your
show for you tell you what why are you
posting this you want to have one but
you feel like no no you know what this
poo never called me on my way to ask me
to be honest but all the one or you get
one in history when you're gonna have
yeah you know who helped who does all
that comedians I've never heard of like
I went on my teens and all of a sudden
hey let me be on yours I leave my little
my were you performing at like ten
followers no I'm not in the budget
I don't know you like Filipa don't
follow you then you're not no bro this
fool did it Marco Ramos said Lamar Odom
did right way he'll will died in the - a
bunny ranch in making a bunny ranch and
almost died yeah
and he had a bunch of people there yeah
he did almost die huh he had a stroke or
somebody was in the hospital he did I
don't
all right then all right you want to do
these little the tour dates and stuff
bollocks getting seated all right people
I got my glasses on so don't get scared
upcoming shows I'm going through the
Brea of where the Brea improv
okay other shows are so loud except
except no the rock sold out because you
didn't see is no Friday but if you're
watching on YouTube we have taken
therefore Thursday and we added a second
show 9:30 Sunday
see you there I think there's only like
I think there are maybe only 20 tickets
for Thursday
okay literally 20 tickets
August 30th September 2nd Labor Day
weekend and the Maria improv sold out
except Sunday 9:30 Atlantic City New
Jersey September 7 at the Borgata
Borgata Washington DC September 8 at the
National Harbor Casino Las Vegas
September 14 Laughlin Nevada the number
15 Lexington Kentucky September 20 or 22
we're bringing marching rizal to this
show so check it out Springfield
Massachusetts October 9
check out Felipa world comes back to
Raleigh upcoming show that secure
information Victorian has a young man
podcast that's still going strong go
check out the yo-yo your part camera
Marty Moreno Jorge Perez stories with
Jorge Perez and sidekick Eddie and the
other homie go check out the Tommy Hicks
and Jamal Doman podcast dope dealer
podcast daily also go check out the
other or our sister podcast the drama
club podcast and oh we just became
produced co-producers of row of roughly
mais pas unbelievable we're gonna get a
screeners copy of one of wrong females
never before release
HBO specials now his first album he ever
recorded yeah it's never been released
[Laughter]
ok first of all before we get to them
I'll talk about how I know the movie bro
you know me but I watch a lot of YouTube
video I read that a bunch of books you
know we read those books about that guy
boxer Enrique's yeah we went the other
book about the Mexican Mafia the guy
wrote Raphael the lawyer Tony Raphael
Tony Raphael and of course America me
and blood in blood out and we happy we
have Michael on the show we have Gilbert
Collier they get hook at the Night
Stalker but bro I'm telling you man when
ice to watch YouTube there was there was
this guy on the show who was talking him
name was Kilroy and he was talking bro
and like he was an old gentleman and
very very very um well with words broke
he was talking about you know changing
your life and all that
and then I looked I found him through a
gang a gang video that was posted atop
up and then well you know bro I got into
it broke his story and I was wanting him
to having a podcast and then we talked
to mark
we were marked for a wonderful wife is
yeah because a recovering addict to
Kilroy from White Fence 223 yeah put it
three years sober bro and um but you
know what was it true I'm going into
like them everything bringing on me bro
and you you - you love every type of us
we like to subculture the underworld the
underworld bro we like we like to hear
story from real people brother wanna
unsung heroes Raza primary sources that
so there's a movie coming out about
Kilroy his real name is should I find
out got my glasses
maybe Kilroy World War Ernest curie
Roybal bro that's me was taking with
that politician it's a political family
the roy balls here now is he related to
him by any chance I don't think so no
yeah that names pretty rare too so they
made a movie about Kilroy his life I
stopped what we done yeah we filmed it
this is Paul yeah I'm Paul I'm the
executive producer Alice he's a
filmmaker interventionalist poison
graduated from Community Care generation
from project kinship sister organization
to homeboy industry how we have
something in common I know I huh boy
industry help me out with it before when
there was jobs for the future and where
you are I've seen you in movies yeah and
I've been following you on Instagram for
quite a while we had two guys on our
show that know you too
there are they're video of cholos eat
sushi cholos try yeah Carly so yeah get
started the movie what made you start to
move away well you know growing growing
up but you grew up by the way sorry Paul
I grew up in La Habra West Side Lahab
Rho star we have a bro we had a gap of
Harbor City here different area ha
yeah that's over there by Martina yeah
yeah Oh Harbor is thanks Whittier
I don't wanna Orange County has right by
Brea bro well let's first there you go
Krispy Kreme yes and let me tell you man
you know I was sober when you're sober
you pick up other stuff to do besides
them you know putting drugs in your body
so my friend stearate Felipe you want to
go drive 40 minutes you some eat some
good stuff I said boy you know drugs I
was having Donuts so I drove 45 minutes
and I waited in line for an hour for
doughnuts there I remember I remember
those days man raising time but but
Christmas everywhere hell yeah but don't
let the only one yeah now a closed-down
man too many too many of them
the original closed down that's that
well it's disrupted with food again I
love it yeah so we started this movie on
you know I've been to the joint grew up
a rough life threw up a gang member a
shot caller so Kilroy was one of those
guys that uh was always he's one of the
cofounders of the Mexican Mafia you know
he was there from the beginning so he
was there with WeDo buff he was there
from the start so as a gang member in
prison he was always one of my even
though I didn't know him he was one of
my shot callers you know one of the
people who was over for us you know and
he was a big name there's not really
many names bigger than his you know in
the system you know you have these guys
Joe Morgan and all them but Kilroy was
one of the biggest so being as that
getting out changing my life you know
through many things going to school me
and Kilroy became good friends
and this story just had to be told you
know growing up here in White Fence 40
years in prison murder you know just
every time how did I read that he was
born in 1939 yes he did 40 years think
he came by in 1994 was before that made
him lose too much time
he he got busted for all kinds of stuff
but ultimately in the middle of that he
got caught for a murder you know
obviously we didn't side many yeah
inside inside Chino he got caught for a
murder
and you know he did a lot of time
through this is his words through rich
appeals in the grace of God he got out
and now his mission is to reach gang
members you could find a pair in white
fence you could find them everywhere bow
Heights is his heart you know reaching
people you know so one knew was locked
up in there I I know when I'm watching
his um his video he was talking about
how he has relatives that I thought they
were never there and he grew up and he
taught he spoke to them you know don't
be so hard another another living in a
shoe for like 18 years straight
yeah man he was there security how the
Union by the way yeah he was there man
he was there lockdown pretty sure you
know what in the hole I've been in a
whole lot of that what's the longer
you've been in the hole probably six
months so that is that legal
it was a time someone it was total
darkness or was there no this you're
being a bathroom yeah pretty much no
book nothing no you got books I'll get
looks you get books and even like when I
was at Tracy prison which is gladiator
school or the mock Mexican Mafia started
after ten days they give you a TV when I
was there
now Kilroy is dead that's different you
know children would grow up in a harder
time you know I think it was more of
what she would picture you know mm-hmm
so yeah the first time I heard that I
bought about Tracy being the gladiator
school because that's that's a prison
SNU right after why a right yeah I went
there at 18 19 years old grew up and I
remember staying on man you know you
always hear in the county jail it's
gonna be on with the norteños you know
so I'm ready to see what's the north
Danian which he looked like you know
when you get there and they had the
tales and the long hair right so we get
there and you know it is what it is it
had calmed down a little by the time I
got there but uh I was still jumping off
a little you know I don't remember man
when I was on when I stopped kind of
like doing drugs like in the 1990 92
like Robert Boyle Heights right there
and now a peak or at least for housing
projects and when I remember when I was
in rehab and when I came out I was
working with an old man and he was from
arabiya
and
he didn't know what's going on he said
he hasn't been in the game for a long
time and he wouldn't he went inside for
a warrant and when he got out he what
happened he was all matter know what
happened but I had like ten little
homies in the old home we trying to stab
me in there I don't know my father's a
green light and my homies yeah I'm out
of the game though all from out of here
he for mother yeah yeah when I was there
and the last time I was there at Chino -
there was guys in there who were from
MonaVie a Christian - whatever you know
they were doing good you know there were
you know there's fake Christians and
they're the real ones - for real yeah
but even though they through their
mouths you know Jay had they had to get
off the word you know and it was crazy
you know when I was in rehab I was a
rehab at live again recovery homes if
anybody looking for a rehab is live
again recovering home with Pastor Juan
and look him up I was there and I was
over we were there it started off like a
six-month program it we were six of us
and we were living in the valley but
then we grew we took a lot of people
from Fresno and Madera and then we moved
to just Saugus yeah we have our own
little camp and then we laid a lot of a
minute I got my hair cut did from our
old dude he cut my hair with razor
blades
I know you like my hair never Sonny
biased arrows he was an old man him he
did he said he won the middleweight
champion and for something probably man
probably that was Kilroy sunny by
esteros yeah sounds familiar
yeah the old man you know he the barber
and he bought in a boxer he had his hair
was he from I don't know man no I think
he was probably Bible URI really maybe
but he had out he was old man when I was
in rehab he was a really 5060 yeah he's
here like here are white here on which
the backs move and a nice little old
mustache and he do the boxing matches
you cut your hair with the razor huh
yeah those man
and you know there was another guy hey
there was chewy you were focalized on
Chewie
it's was katana and that guy man
will rehab man what's that dude man he
said he was lucky the first time he did
was eight years nine oh nine straight
got out he loved somebody a favor we're
back into another eight row and then
like they would tea routine routine you
know you see like they were in heroin
yeah that's what I'm hoping with other
choice huh well I wasn't really a
druggie man I was more of a gangster but
be honest with you it was in you know I
would drink beer but I was violent you
know I was violated you know I don't
have a drug of choice you know maybe a
cheeseburger no but uh nah who are you
into it you were a drug dealer what
no I was just a gangster me shooting I
was a gangster yeah I was a gangster and
then eventually you know I went to the
county and then I was in the tank and
somebody told me this guy has to be
taken out and you know I didn't stab
them you know we'd have a knife but beat
him up and ended up being one of the
shot callers that Glover fell out of
favor and that gave me status from there
grew and grew and grew until you know yo
yo yo check check check check on your
oh good someone got too much bass in
their voice Oh what happened yeah we can
keep going just the headphones
okay corty okay what's up boo okay thank
you Alex there we go go um you were born
in New Jersey yeah how'd you make it out
to Ali oh it's a long story but they
shortened it up my dad was a journeyman
operator for Glass Company Glass Company
started closing because aluminum and
plastic and he we were first moved to
Texas dental Pennsylvania and graduated
Pennsylvania were Mike Piazza played
ball there in high school in
Phoenixville and then came out here when
I was 20 and I got into gangs and
basically no Mexican but the only
Mexican in a Puerto Rican in town in
Dover yeah no what would you get into
acting I was doing drugs and doing all
kinds of bad things was in music for a
long time like a rapper about that yeah
and I got clean I still wanted to do
some type of entertainment got involved
with Sons of Anarchy my friends had a
car club okay with techniques ballpark
and got on there and then started taking
classes because I wanted to expand
instead of just doing background work
yeah 2011 I've been doing some things
after that kind of shameless and
something doing some good things real
killed my first lead so how did you get
do late the film industry as far as what
how'd you get started level your first
documentary our first documentary I
think was I've done a lot of little
films but then I did a documentary on
Kilroy I did dr. mater gots done you
know whatever and that that could be
gotten through homies to Christ who
straight directly through Kilroy I've
been casting with Justin Shauna the
Twilight series for the MOOC and went to
Sundance I'd help do the casting there I
got the Latino actors and that's a whole
nother story you know and just always
been
I was never in the cliquish media crowd
yeah but uh you know I've I've always
been kind of like into it you know and
this movie what we hope to do with
Kilroy is gonna be the you know like a
lot of the movies you say blood in blood
out
American me they're not like based on
reality like they have the Mafia
starting like later yeah yeah like
they're them they starting it like they
have the wrong guys starting it for the
first place so well where ours is gonna
be like the most probably the most
accurate movie that's ever been done on
the story you know on the movie we try
to keep it accurate as possible myself
and then my co-executive producers like
he's like an expert on the subject also
so we're not trying to disrespect no one
but we are trying to tell a story of
hope we're getting to the ugliest we're
trying to kill Roy silent killer his
story the way it was the ugliness and
when he became a Christian we're showing
that too we're not cutting out nothing
we're gonna be real and faith-based yeah
it's some political correctness people
might not like it but is that just for
the bad and the Christian stuff Duke of
Earl kind of had a little of the world
right at the end they show the change
you know kind of darkness to the light
we've always been seeing each other
actually like some family groups and
church and stuff meeting together as a
filmmakers and actors and stuff and then
uh there was another film that saw him
do and you know just bumping into each
other here and there and he hit me up
one day and wanted to do a kill Roy and
was uh you know offered me an audition
for the yeah we are we're at a we're at
a the first time we met we're at a thing
with uh Michael Pena oh yeah yeah at
that function in LA was just right there
a part that Kilroy you know we didn't
know each other yet well that guy looks
like Kilroy yeah and then who would have
known years later I pop up pop appeals
piece of pizza and Anaheim best pizza
around I did a cast out
I did a casting and he was the first one
we you know we auditioned and he killed
it and from there on I had to tell a lot
of Wilson's friends who were hoping for
the part to that a Charlie first guy got
it Wilson killed it and he was a guy and
I'm so glad because integrity honesty
and he memorized the whole script he
came to set memorized the whole script
he didn't you have to give a paper bro
so that's a pro yeah like background
well I talked to Kilroy I did research
when he walked yeah I did a little bit
and due to a little bit of your own
Wilson of course of course
laughter yeah cuz I mean I've been
around enough seeing some things and I
grew up in Boyle I mean didn't grow up
and I hung out in Boyle Heights and
there were more to garner projects so
we're very close to each other so
definitely I used what I knew my unique
technique as my coach tells me and yeah
put it together try to put away of the
the accent I have a little East Coast
accent I have try to get it try to keep
it more subtle but that's it yeah
somebody's job was in the prime suspect
ed was though Oh prime suspects there
was some myself at the all suspects
losing a group called the suspect nation
so that's tight shout out to the
suspects there you go brother you know
his rap name nobody rap name and they
make that on ok ok yeah yeah no I should
be called lefty/lefty bro you got it
yeah no more Lefty
hello righty hello this bill takes to
film we did it in about uh about a month
and a half
whoa a lot of month in 12-hour days yeah
we did but we did weekends because we
had a huge cast of like I mean for us
for an independent film like 70 people I
mean you have 70 inmates coming in one
day Wow you need to get everybody there
you know not everybody could be there on
a Monday or a Tuesday and a lot of the
people like we're all friends like
everybody you know the community though
yeah Amelio everybody knows each other
right Luigi so exactly
he's only wonder wasn't in it
perfect Ben Hector
so Paul did you run into or do you think
you'll run into any uh any problems like
you know like with that happened with
edward james olmos an american me know
you know stuff like that were the these
original members or these other members
get mad at you're talking about this you
know you know like when I talked to
Kilroy we did it we did it well
specifically to reach kids and to reach
youth that they the gang members
specifically in Boyle Heights and in my
area where I grew up that they would see
another way no I didn't grow up on
killing yeah so so I haven't ran into
nothing and I think a lot of the stuff
was Edward James almost could have been
avoided because because the
fictionalization Cheyenne getting killed
by his own people
Cheyenne getting yeah you're right that
did it happen yeah a lot of that stuff
and I read that on the bio about Hill
Road that their whole thing could have
been avoided and cuz it happened that
the whole beef started between north of
son overshoes right yeah out of that
story it start it happened kind of
before that it happened kind of before
that there was uh the the the super
angels the the guys from there
the guys from the south always kind of
looked down to the guys in the north you
know it was always a thing they didn't I
mean not all of our bursa not all of
them not all they were by size no no
farmers yeah I don't know you know I I
wouldn't know the word but but they kind
of looked down on him but don't get me
wrong there was guys there was guys um
from up north or in the m82 who were in
the Mexican Mafia but for the most part
they didn't like them and eventually you
know when you get bullied so much they
want to come back yeah they want to come
back and so one day one day one of the
suitor angels one of the Emmy guys was
going passing by a cell seen some shoes
took him and they happened to be to a
nurse Ralph Amelia Gaia
you know the northern mafia took the
shoes when and gave them they didn't fit
so he gave him to some guy named robot
Salah everybody know Trejo knows this
guy he's
now but we lost our last robot Silas
gave it gave it to robot gave him to
robot robots on the yard and then the
northern guy sees hey those are my shoes
and confronts them and then those are my
shoes we're gonna get down later and
robot just went back and got a knife and
took care of it pretty quick and that's
kind of like how the north south and
then Kilroy his part is that they knew
something was brewing so they locked him
down they put they locked him down
because you know he was one of the shot
collars so they locked him down before
he could get involved you know stuff
like that
she was the shoe wars man that's big
there's a there's a book called the shoe
washer wars by mundo Mendoza moon de
Mendoza yeah mermen the way he played
please play my big dog Mario
no he's Monday he's money money we had
big Mario here on the show tonight I've
seen it man I followed the podcast he
did good care of me
shut up to big Mario Big Dawg he wasn't
getting apart candy on me Mariano wow
man that's crazy than all over the shoes
and stuff yeah man and it went on you
know and and then I read that that the
original guy one of the guy who he
wanted to make a peace with north and
south well Cheyenne Cheyenne Cheyenne
20ms try anchored there now he wanted to
make a peace treaty
we touched that we touched the shoe war
we touch on that in the movie the movie
in the moat very sensitive yeah we touch
on that in the movie and we show a
conversation that Kilroy had with him
the killer I didn't agrees like bro
you're your own man but go ahead you
know go ahead but I don't agree with it
be careful
being that that that's an actual history
event did you guys try to keep it
exactly the way it happened you know a
Hollywood twist you okay keep everybody
happy
no no it's close but what but what it is
you know he got thrown off the tear you
know whoa in real life he got thrown off
the tear so by a little homeboy the
other fools know by the northern guys
his own cousin actually to set him up
huh its own cousin he I went down there
little cousin was one of the northern
guys and threw him off the turn we try
to stay close bro but you know what we
do like there were so many prisons over
so much time you guys start actually in
prisons no we shot at uh at a movie
studio okay and uh please call forget in
Anaheim
all silver streams inspector so so in
other words like this happened at Folsom
this happened in Quinton this happened
in Tracy this happened and in solid ad
so because of that it would be too
confusing to show all these different
things so we just kind of kept it more
in one you know one prison so to speak
you know almost not not really but you
know to keep it as simple as possible
so starting the movie it's gonna say
like further movie you know just that's
the only thing you're gonna see
different you know because now we're at
Folsom now we're at Point a now we're at
Tracy would be too much for a movie you
know did you did you find it difficult
to direct a movie cuz I don't a lot of
pressure on you for that movie yeah it's
it was hard there was there was a time
we were filming Saturday we're like bump
him with Wilson over the acting skills
no no miss Ramirez like Richard ya know
anybody out there and he's the most
professional actor I've ever worked with
think seriously is Wilson give my kinda
ghetto money on Marina nothing up listen
I stay about out about other masters
will go to go to four years and think
about Fine Arts degrees wait why is it
that comedians and people with a rough
background can act because we've been
lying the whole time I just need to get
a little technique in and that was it
yeah I thank God if you don't want to
join the Wilson I've told you about
Marian acting class yeah just do some
dog we're pretending get loaded and
you'll be fine well yeah yeah I think
the main thing for the movies that we we
saw it was in all respect and it's
faith-based and it's the only reason why
cuz I didn't want to offend you know
anybody you know any of the any of the
big the big homies and not like that and
definitely wanted to keep it as true as
possible and that's what that's what the
directors did I was glad you know cuz I
think it's a good movie cuz it like I
said it talks about light the dark into
the light and it's a message it's not
just like you know the ugly and that's
it there's he changed and a lot of
things could have happened
and things didn't and I think it's
because a higher power that I like to
call God came in and and and and ease
things and you know make things great
what happened that dude did he end up
debriefing or like Kilroy no he never
did never like he was in 1994 right yeah
1990 40 years of his life
yeah him Bigby how about people see
those three right I want to see these
fifties I want to say because he's like
780 now in short shiny things that we're
doing take your you do life that's what
they do is take your life yeah yeah they
came out he came out a little angrier to
society when the giana go back to the
his bad ways or yeah confused about
going good or bad
no what happened is there was inner
fighting between the old guys and the
young guys you know a lot of the younger
guys are being I mean a lot of older
guys were being hit and stabbed and
killed Roy you know called out a few of
them and and one of the younger guys
stabbed him and he ended up you know
they underpin to Pelican Bay once you're
in Pelican Bay you can't really get to
people because you're locked down 23
hours a day you know so when you don't
worry no no no I haven't been to Pelican
Bay that's it another but San Pedro
under under the boy right no that's over
by organ the organ board gonna be I'm
sorry what'd I say I don't know but
anyway so he got out and he wanted to
take care of business to take some heads
and kill or was that type of person he
didn't cross and but what happened one
day he was it was all strung out and a
little old lady came up to him and
preached the gospel to him and from that
day forward that changed his life
you know Jesus changed his life you know
that's all it was mmm now being that way
you're not so your name is supposed to
get out of that life right no what
happened with that how was he able to
transition he to him it was blood in
blood out and he is his words I'm out
because the blood of Jesus Christ so he
says when when you really serve God that
God's gonna put up a hedge of protection
over you you know and I protect him so
by that time though when he when he got
saved there was already another original
member
the Mexican Mafia named Donald Garcia
Big D who was saved so killer I just
followed into that and now he has
another guy pretty Bob there's art blah
host Cornell Hall from East LA there's
all these guys that are out of the Mafia
serving the Lord on the streets yeah
yeah oh he had a story that they came up
to him when he was preaching and he told
them all right but if you change we're
gonna come back yes they didn't they
didn't debrief they'd never told these
guys never rolled on their friends
because they felt that it wasn't their
job to be a cop their job was to tell
people about Jesus their job wasn't to
tell what what they did in the pastor
rat on their friends right now the you
got other guys like boxer and Rica's
mundo Mendoza they testified against the
Mafia put Joe Morgan away pegleg they
they put him away but to them to like
but but don't get me wrong
mundo Mendoza he testified whatever but
he was one of the biggest killers in the
Mexican Mafia man he was a stone-cold
killer probably killed more than anybody
except robot so he works with the feds
now but I mean that guy's wrote a lot of
books if you want to do a lot of history
on mundo mondo mondo Mendoza and that
was again a kind of save his life right
yeah yeah but he also said he's also
became a Christian so he said God
changed his life I mean I never met the
guy but I know friends who know him and
so he's the real deal he's really a
walking with God you know natural that
um Joe Morgan nature transfer him by
helicopter because he was a he was a
risk you know I don't know about that
but I know I know they transferred for a
trial they transferred some of them
called Dumbo the Dumbo drop I remember
that yeah they took a couple of them but
I was in I was in Corcoran in I was in
Corcoran I was one of the shot callers I
was there when Joe Morgan died you know
when Joe Morgan Morgan within the
hospital they answer right
yeah the stomach cancer they brought him
down from Pelican Bay and they brought
him in an escort that's why I bring it
up they brought him in an escort and I
was there when he died and when he died
it was just like another day there her
like you know is he buried in Boyle
Heights or butter
you know I don't know I don't think he's
in a prison yard he had loved ones bro
wasn't he he's a mafia right yeah I
think it was from Mario yeah yeah he was
like do you know anymore one of the
flats African Russian right yeah
something like that
he's a full-on white boy though right
you go Slava yeah something like that
yeah
wouldn't if it was a shoe worse go down
with you was a shoot I want to say the
mid 70s when was the Mexican Mafia
started probably the idea was in 1958
idea yeah no that was Tracy that's it
that wasn't Tracy there's our old okay
there's an old tattoo or an old um when
you look up the Mexican Mafia some old
thing and if you have a cross on it yeah
it's not about our names and curiously
yeah the original guys are most of those
are neighborhood I don't exist like
Vicki's town was wrong that from Colton
there still is still yeah Vicki's town
or and yeah Vicki ficky
yeah pick is still there yeah as you
know again for picking it up yeah and
you guys are shopping this movie and not
shopping you guys are going to show this
movie in churches first right well what
we're gonna do like the Tyler Perry well
with the distributors right now right
the editing is just getting done right
you have to killer guys from Long Beach
some black dudes doing it they're
awesome they're gonna finish it up and
end up there and then from there we need
to decide like you know because we're
not we're not Stephen King we don't have
multi-million dollars what's best for us
to do a to do a little you know some
theaters or to go straight for in
digital you know what I mean like for us
financially a Film Festival me probably
not yeah I think either way we get it
from both sides you know movie or
documentary movie two hours and two
hours and then you know we think about
it like this Kilroy was involved in from
the start to now the Mexican Mafia so we
couldn't cover all that time it so if
you Forrest Gump he was here he was
there different generations that's how
we're kind of doing the movie and we're
gonna have a voice over by a certain
celebrity that can't say right here
is gonna do the voiceover that's going
to carry it on from generation to
generation - good bro what were the
other things that kind of go through
every Jane is almost in trouble that
were they showed Cheyenne
dominating raped and that other one ever
happened passing the drugs that bolon
also I think I'll put you there nobody
knew that was happening
maybe well there were certain things
like the black Italian mafia it was
never it was always her size too many
secrets yeah so little actual Italian
here at one time there still is man it
was I know that there's I read because
you ever remember I'm cheap to rotates
yeah yeah
LAPD okay I read it I read his book for
some reason I read the whole book and he
said that there was a mob but that mob
here in that lays was real small but
very strong and whenever a new mob guy
moving from from New York to come here
to be don't start off any any kind of
any kind of money-making deal that does
that guy making coin he would have that
guy beat that they beat the crap out of
him put him back on a plane and send him
back to New York every time I knew every
time an Italian guy moved to LA chief
third part was sent his goon squad under
you guys saw that movie with Nick Nolte
where he's just beating up a bunch of
who's in that movie alley confidential
hmm and that really happened so there's
Russell Crowe these cops will just beat
up Italians that will show up so they
won't start no crews in LA because they
had a crew and that crew with the
Italians and LAPD yeah yeah I was busted
with a mobster from here his name was
Mike Rizzo cello he's passed away now
he's buried over in Palm Springs and and
he had Jimmy the weasel frediano the
book the last month frost mafioso they
were all out here so they're you know
they call him the Mickey Mouse mafia but
they were hardcore
so that that what happened to American
me with when they went to go speak to
the Italian guy in house
that was actual real there was actually
a heroin dealer Italy you know I'm not
sure about that but they're one of the
mobsters I knew who was passed away now
he was there was though he was connected
really late here about the early mafia
huh know if you look at Little Italy
that's Chinatown now yeah if you if you
look him up there like they were called
the Milano family I'm sure the family
still around it did Pete Milano yeah if
you google them that's the name I'm
pretty sure I mean every percent Greek
Italian Bella Paris yeah there's only
one there's that little Italian
restaurant there's a little Italian
restaurant that East Side deli or
whatever that's right next to China
tonight that might be the last little
italy place that's laughs yeah because
during World War two when they were
never like good gathering where we were
to happen and must leave me that
involved the backlash against Italians
and Chinese people and Koreans and
Japanese people so a lot of the
restaurants closed down the original one
I'm supposed to be in Chinatown with uh
was the load though there's something
turtle I used to be right there with a
gas station in the channel ten it was
the one that looks like Spanish mission
style yes abandoned forever Tommy
Lasorda what's up or jiggle when she got
done chillin September 11
Brewers at California because it was
jokes nice Brea so do you do testimonies
before that ever like a church is he
talk about your whole story
oh it's funny we just talking about that
my friend Mariano big dog he had
testimony that was gonna be involved in
and I had had to work on myself a little
bit with my character defects so I'm
back on working my stuff again but yeah
so when we get the chance we'd love to
share and stuff and I got more stories
to help people get you know you are you
also daddy yeah well he does a choice
everything but oh okay oh yeah you been
through that right do i I was relating
to everything you're saying all the calm
down no a fresh word
we are listeners here people who reach
out reach out it always ask me Philippe
Esparza and I thought I know that your
recovery and I just did some crack I'll
try to stop those were like talking I
said listen right now only me and you
know this hmm he goes maybe you should
go into a meeting right now if you want
to or don't don't use tomorrow and then
the next day don't use again but walk
into a meeting when they get some help
but but what better effort was going
through we all go through that right the
UPS the crying yeah eating
jack-in-the-box mister things I've been
telling myself and it's gonna sound how
well I've learned I've learned cuz I'm
actually paying attention because if for
a minute I wasn't doing steps anymore I
was just I was just um
just trying you know that's right tries
bad yeah so I learned that I gotta be
accountable I have to have transparency
limitations people places or things
associations and I have to be um open
open-minded and I can't be overconfident
and when I'm overconfident like you were
talking about Ben being like two days
and then you know you're like you got it
again you start feeling that itch and
you have to go back to being open and
telling people like I asked them to be
accountable to me I got opened up to
them today because it's pretty fresh you
know what happened in my life and I
don't mean to take up the whole time
with this thing and just like that's
just where I was at you know I was uh I
was shooting myself down I was a
sabotaging myself and I was a lot of
great things was happening in my life
and I told them help me be accountable
you know like like ask me am i doing and
and I gotta be open like a you know I
feel like I tell my wife now like yeah I
don't feel too good today you know and
she goes or what I do and I'm you know
up when I get open then it kind of
leaves you know but if I stay quiet and
isolate and you know the mind starts
going that's that's an important thing
because sometimes Philippe will turn to
me and say something that scares me
you go no that's but it scares me but I
know now
I know now when you say something like
this morning I woke up and I felt like
using or I had a dream where I smoked
crack last night whatever you'll tell me
that but for a second wait yeah Lee you
seem a little too excited about it or
what something scares me when you say it
and this is different because we've been
through the war sorry like we're like oh
yeah I felt like this and you're like
and for me I'm just thinking okay when
is this next binge gonna start right and
I'm waiting for the other shoe to drop
but I I try to be quiet now I understand
that right now I understand now that
you're just letting it out like like
you're saying you're just releasing that
and then I don't need to do anything
about it I just need to listen to you is
that I never thought about that
the overcome is what stood out Tony
Ramirez yeah yeah you said over
overconfident yeah what really helped me
work Ramirez when you stay at the
overconfident that right there is thank
them when I man
it's the power man that's when you get
to the point where you're sober and then
you're overconfident that's when you
want to go you want to but you ask your
father or we gonna ask your wife or you
ask whoever is helping you out you know
what I'm gonna get into hiking now and
they buy your hiking shoes in a backpack
and you saw that [ __ ] buddy yeah you
know it's funny my friend and we went to
my friends house and this is just after
like a couple of things are happening
now I'm cleaned up now and I'm doing
better but he opened his front door just
you know because he had to let somebody
out and the door said front door right
so I was like hey we needed one of those
in my house you know that so my wife
knows when I'm leaving and then
everybody started telling jokes like
chimney like he's going through the
chimney like it was just funny you know
cuz you gotta make jokes about that
stuff because um it's real and like I
said like you and my wife they have to
they have to deal with it but they're
there and they're in the fight with us
you know also something good over here
that Hector would you know this right
here coming from the background you have
Paul in our background we haven't learn
our post-traumatic stress disorder like
you know like we actually like we seen
[ __ ] you know that when you see a guy
who just went to the Marines and he
fired Iraq I mean we didn't go out there
but we witnessed the same type of
violence yeah like there's no shooting
outside you know you know you like
running outside and watching somebody
get shot yeah we might get shot in front
of me I saw this guy get stabbed when I
was eight in that I never like dealt
with it you know cuz I'm not gonna say
we're white but we don't have the
support system to know the support
system that may be like your dream I
have dreams that you're being shot at or
you you're running or you you just you
just drank a beer that you regret it
mmm see I have those that's left PTSD
yeah I don't know what to do yeah it's
like that it's like that but yeah the I
mean I go to meeting pray I have a
sponsor that doesn't work anymore
yeah I get more open now I don't isolate
I go to church but I said I was living a
double life still you know I wouldn't
tell everybody everything oh I'm good I
wouldn't say I was good but I'm not
working it out because I knew I'll be
lying by saying good to myself so I
would say like I'm you know little by
little getting there you know so so I
didn't sound like you know they always
talk about dangers like all of you
always say you're good but are you good
so I would say like I'm I'm working it
out you know so I talk to people I try
and get as open as possible to people
that are gonna listen especially hitting
meetings and then working the steps
which if you don't work the steps then
you're just doing homework assignments
right that's what I heard in in a
meeting one day and it stuck and it's
like just gotta go no matter what my
friends tell me no matter what you got a
gangster that they tell me no matter
what you got a gangster he was mad
like that's like a that cookie said
another way breeze like it's a girl move
like what you did like it so good why
you know like the hardcore ones to tell
you the idea is a girl Bubo but at the
same time like Felipe made the culture
you're coming from not Latino culture
but the the ghetto the girl the hood
culture that mentality talking about
this stuff is taboo talking about your
feelings rocking about you know a scary
dream you had talking about fear of you
know falling off the wagon again or
whatever it might be that it yeah I mean
it's easy it's hard to hold it in but
that's what you're taught to do about
anything like that about any sort of
feeling like I was something like just
say I will see looking sad and I come a
beachy way yeah don't cry excuse me they
say Americans whales yeah how do you do
that was like lost I was like man I
can't don't have it in me to say you
think something's wrong with you for
having this tension in your brain like
how do I deal with this and then come
the drugs and alcohol to quiet it down
you know and that's it's too bad yeah
that's true man I I find myself to like
you know I'm like isolated sometime at
night but that's what that's a bad I
when I was in rehab isolation is the
devil's playground
it is so you have to money you start to
get about so many stuff huh yeah I give
hugs now I do used to hug I always sit
down in the chair you know I wouldn't I
would hug only who I knew and if I
didn't know yeah I can hook you burn
everybody any you have to hug people in
it you have to get out of yourself you
know because it's important especially
for your own for your own spirituality
because once I start isolating then it's
like you said the devil's playground
crazy-cool a car robbery scruncho let's
say the same thing like all I needed was
a hug I was just a kid I needed a hug
well I heard him scruncho
you know years ago for my cabs each
other's funny story about getting locked
up for the first time and you're there
in prison no hidden jail either [ __ ] and
he saw one of his homies even with the
essays so man me and my homie we shut up
[ __ ] we can be minute we had a meeting
of two of us and we were he went to
hence I went to my side and they told we
try to get both sides together the
message ends and the blacks so we just
we just did messages to return we that's
crazy it was funny my head cuz though
well you were in sports of the kid yeah
play ball play boy
well you little boy was there something
you wanted to be besides the life you
had shoot a Supreme Court judge but now
my outlaw was the first Mexican Supreme
Court judge in California was the man
Cruz Reynoso so straight no so he's the
one that went after those kids the
Orange County because they didn't want
to let the class you know I don't I
don't know I don't know he's way up
there he when we said their Chavez was
working in the fields he was the one
doing the loss so he wasn't one of
Sacramento getting the laws passed that
helped you know the Mexican the Chicano
you know so that was him in different
movies about him like sowing the seeds
of justice so that's what I wanted to
but I went the other way
you know Wow and you I wanted to be a
baseball star me too bro my brother
actually got drafted by the Indians in
the night in 1990 with Cesar Ramirez no
you got drafted minor leagues Ricky Bahl
but he never he went to come
got the call man he got you know
exciting it is I wonder like besides
like when I when I go to college is I'm
something I wanted to myself man I was
sure to wait here for four years in San
Francisco there's a big court building
over a library without these 70 steps
that go all the way down right but it's
a library and it goes people are reading
out there they're smoking weed and
they're hanging out and we were here we
have a another community Marty Moreno he
from Wilmington and he's we passed by
those steps you know II thought
Wilmington man he sees a badge here to
Wilma's and he sort of steps and he goes
I just wanna stay low stay like those
people would and do whatever you read
that you wanna see it you can sit right
now stupid but you know I know where he
ends I know he meant he wanna be like
damn like she just sit there be normal
right without without ticket above III
go through a line of why I know when I
do my comedy I know traveling I love
meeting people I like to sit in place it
word no homie has ever sat on it but
then my homie could just see the chaser
likes
yeah yeah so we're fortunate we're here
so pause what you said you had this
dream to be a Supreme Court justice you
know I could see him what what would
meet you and you didn't have a drug
vice that wasn't your thing what made
you
attracted to the gang life yeah and how
old were you when you started your high
you know you start seeing that uh you
know we have friends you know we used to
we used to you know play together and
all that stuff and whatever but then we
start ditching and then we see you see
in the hood really what you see is you
see the cops busting the older guys that
you think are cool you know their dress
really nice they have the nice cars you
see the cops busting them and they're
like you know you become anti cop
automatically yeah you know and actually
a lot of them there to help us but you
become anti cop and then you see that
and then before you know they're the
enemy these are the guys I want to hang
next to you know you're hanging out with
them and next you know you get in that
position as a gang member you start
recruiting and that's what I did I
started recruiting you know recruiting
people and so it's like a little bit of
power yeah and I ain't gonna lie a lot
of it was a you know it's a fun life
I've still got people this day from the
hood that are brothers you know they say
them brothers you know there's still my
good friends but just I chosen another
path so hopefully they could follow ya
and not only that with the killer a
movie hopefully more people will follow
me come out yeah we were shooting for a
late September which is next month but
dude it we had to fire an editor and get
the new editors which are ten times
better and then so we're looking
probably mid October so the decisions
gonna be made within the next two weeks
are you sitting there with a with an
editor with heredity Oh next week next
week yeah I'll be sitting with them at a
church can we go see it
oh yeah how about you guys to the
premiere we'll have a premiere deciding
that he's there talking to have but
we're definitely gonna have a premiere
we're definitely gonna show it in some
churches well some what I think won't
because of the subject matter you know
even in the other I was victory I'll
reach no no no I'm gonna go to a Calvary
Chapel Calvary yeah I go to Calvary
Chapel starting with you right by the no
that one no that one was started in
Costa Mesa okay by Chuck Smith and
that's what Kilroy follows don't really
started when he started at calvary
chapel and he been through Victory
Outreach and then I forget where he goes
now I think maybe
my brother angel he's in Mexico now by
able to rehab and now with robbery she
was without rehab obituaries with the
water if they kicked it out
Nick it's a matter of equality they
kicked him out there were they were a
jump here bro cuz that they were fasting
and everybody was not supposed to eat
all day on Wednesday and that fool that
when everybody was sleeping he snuck out
of the house and went to get a big
bankroll and Mexican city of Commerce
and they was when they were selling
chocolate my brother stole was starting
his chocolate for and asking for tips
and with keeping the tips brought to by
regular food
my brother Beaufighter scam anywhere
that's how addicts work yeah and I don't
care something man
how you like alright how do you catch
yourself for not running a scam the
scams always come to you here right I
don't know how it is how do you stop
thinking like a hustler like it yeah
like sometimes you know like like like I
was doing stand-up comedy and I was
running I would have time I can't be
doing this like only a couple of times
like the money was I was $200 and they
had told me I gotta pay these comedians
so I was like telling them looking like
a biscuit man I'm gonna give you $100 on
paper but you're gonna give me $65 back
I know and they would just say yes don't
questions asked
busty I knew they were going to say yes
because they're not part of the life but
I know I'm getting over on them huh but
I didn't see nothing wrong with it to
later on you know what my um my I did my
sobriety started catching oats of my
personality because I've never
understand basically bullying those guys
so try it how do you how did you get
over that the person of the struggle you
went through the behavior I mean a
behavior you know yeah
working the steps right well I'm stumped
I wasn't working I worked the steps in
the beginning and I stopped and when I
stopped I kept scheming my character
defects showed and so now as I'm reading
I see and I'm only getting to step one I
haven't even done it yet but just the
fact that what I see is so like so I'm
so I'm understanding everything the
books saying I don't read a lot I read
scripts and that's a struggle sometimes
but actually opening the book making
myself read because I don't feel I have
another chance like I really feel like I
gotta do it so like when I read it and I
see all this stuff going on that I'm
doing or I asked my wife for 20 and hey
I asked my son you got ten and then
you'll get 10 I got 30 now so it's like
you know what I mean it's like it's it's
just I got a I got a talk in love and in
peace it's just I can't be doing things
I got a limit my actions with everything
it's crazy
shut up - Mario Cruz I think there's
plenty to draw already he said he came
in late yeah September 11th Riverside
and I'll be in Brea hold Rodrigo tours
in the homie show after that show on
September 5th me if I Rodrigo Torres jr.
on Yahoo now for free passes where can
people go to a webpage to support the
movie Kilroy the movie on Facebook right
ya know or the movie comedy up to two
weeks but Kilroy the movie on facebook
to follow their you could find everybody
there's some videos there too that will
we'll share on your fan page too but
they have some videos like you have a
couple rap songs right the soundtrack is
there a trailer on there too the thing
cool about the movie too is we got a guy
doing the score who worked on Wonder
Woman Pirates of the Caribbean you know
we're trying to do it right with our
minimal budget and you know and that way
I would really encourage anybody out
there like looking into get movies is
why everybody else cuz sag you know what
you didn't say no get me wrong they have
you know
producers they got a lot of go-to guys
and you know so I encourage everybody
out there trying to make a movie rather
than trying to chase investors just
start doing it just do it right just do
it start doing it what's done yeah you
did you put it in there but you sell it
it makes money then you can invest in
another movie you know just start doing
it while everybody else is chasing be
the one who does it
you know that's what I would say you
know because people help you budget you
know there's something you were saving
up no no no it was it was ours it was
ours me and me and my executive
co-producer so you know so my friend
Pete Dillinger he's the one who helped
write the black clansmen he's my partner
in the he did yeah black classmen I want
to see that movie by the way the book so
he won the book yeah you helped put it
together yeah so with Ron and you know
so he was the co-executive producer so
he funded most of it you know so thanks
God you know but still like I just
encourage everybody to do it because
everybody else is running around trying
it for the same in the same pot or start
doing it and get it on Netflix get it
Laden that's how you did you come to
yeah people say oh man these films are
so expensive is only for white people
you can tell some people they can learn
in the internet just google it how do I
make a movie no film sports good honest
and the heart to do something just start
doing it start editing on your computer
hologram exactly exactly I went I went
to film school right here in East LA
East LA skill center I already knew how
to film I knew how to make flyers like I
didn't learn a whole lot but the paper
looks nice the paper looks nice when
you're going in to talk to an investor
or somebody the paper looks nice that
you have that you finished all these
semesters of film school and you learn
to editing you learn filming you learn
like every lighting right Mylene you're
certain that the world
the one by the courtroom by Linkin Park
okay without with this yeah Lincoln Park
I what there was banner if you want to
go there for a carpenter plumber how did
you find film school the thing is you
don't learn as much in the those
classroom settings as you do just doing
it I think there's a website called no
film school go to that a lot from
anybody has a book to write yeah what's
up with the Kilroy what's he doing these
days he was about to be here but he got
who with in Africa he broke he broke his
hip I think it was a missionary trip for
a month long he gets to Africa
now he's 80 years old mind you he gets
to Africa falls on the third day breaks
his knee brought a kill wrote was a
racist brawl he used to hate black
people grow and do not change his life
God change his life but so that so the
third day there rather than he he he
should have came home dude
you should have came home but what
happened he was in so much pain he just
I'm gonna stick it out so he broke his
knee stuck it out the rest of the time
for the love of the people from Africa
he stayed there and came back and now
he's recovering him because of that he's
still laid up basically you got an
infection right or something like that
because he didn't take care of it
there's a breathe air to re-break it
right yeah yeah so they messed up his
other hip so he was doing missionary
work other yeah the prison's not just
preaching reaching the word Ching and
helping uh like giving you know I think
it's sheep or chickens they give that
that's a big thing to give to them and
you know buying stuff so this guy Paul
wants that wants to ask you what video
editing software would you recommend for
a beginner to use because something like
Adobe Premiere has a huge learning curve
iMovie you know what I would I would
practice any on your phone okay about
depends on what computer he has if he
wants to you just wants Final Cut right
in the Mac but I use your Dobby premier
and then there's another one well he's
having a hard time yeah but that's the
one to stick with man and then the other
one is the one from Japan that's really
good
it's CyberLink PowerDirector but if you
put all down on your phone if you put
all your time to doing CyberLink
PowerDirector though later on like when
you start doing Hollywood stuff you're
gonna need premier she might as well
learn premier or final cut now and I
prefer premier okay
they have a brand name oh by the way
avid avid has a free one you could
download a free editing software from
avid - that's pretty good
avid is used by professionals yeah yeah
dope would you think of shoutouts yeah
man
shut us to Laredo in that restaurant
over 800 keep those sorted but your
channel restaurant man that man some
good but such a bomb dude it was really
good he gave me were vegan my how began
doing Oh believe me because I'm so big
what the hell you eat crops I want to
give a shout out one shout out I forgot
the list of other shadows but this is -
what is his name
Alex marine Alex money Oh from Boyle
Heights
shoutout to Mariner from Hilo in Hawaii
his soldiers came back on no I said get
a shout out to Alex marine from this
girl Biddle metal Susie FIFA who is I
guess I don't know if she's his
girlfriend but she loves him and wants
him to know how much she loves him and
all that stuff so no I don't know Alex
marine from oh yeah yeah I want to give
a shout-out to wallet Spinoza he's an
actor he's an actor he's in Kilroy - I
seen him into stuff before he's uh
the outlook no I was just a background
but I got I got booked and thrown in
myself every but I think get in back
you better other stuff before though
little little little things well
actually I was in I played a small part
as a cartel leader in a peppermint we're
listening to be coming out I think on
the seventh day you grew up orderly a
Lee County in seguro Valley
oh yeah appointed by the hot people bull
I still love the hot [ __ ] that's the
only place with a mom and a daughter
[Laughter]
peppers burn down your old school red
onion right there or that Winnie bro
came up that's right that's right learn
my chops bro over the red onion and the
jungle something over there
old schoolers oh man red onion um they
took another one man they say I want it
downtown by the Bonaventure hotel and
they have a look when they woke up
galaxia or or a galaxy or something like
that how most good right to party at the
sea air saw right there our first week I
know donkey horde they say no Papa don't
be hotel mr. J's in El Monte I have to
wait to go out bro I just go ahead I'll
plan Apple Tuesday night I used to go
for two-for-one trees and quiet cabin
Wednesday nights I used to go to the
Riviera a date or somewhere where I went
on Thursdays for Thursday that went back
to quite kind of two-for-one Fridays I
will go to caddies caddies over there on
Friday nights crack Kenny's and Saturday
nights I actually go to the Riviera
where there are Santa Monica you gotta
make sure when you get there man let's
go to the wrong door because the other
door is all gay and trying
but the other part is mcarnold or
Dorian's [ __ ] starts out in a taco
truck so what when how many drinks do
you think you drink on a two for one
night I know you weren't drinking that
time you just wanted gonna pick up a
baby that was cheap because danza oh he
said okay bad it's not cheap he was we
will get there - quite Canada's at eight
people didn't get to to eleven or ten
people still golfing when we get there
for Olympic we do want to pay to get in
man we were there scab or chicks man
shout out to a rage underscore 1355 show
in Lubbock that came out and also Peter
betras from Eagle Pass Texas man what's
up fools chatter - Alex the large he
helped us out of the mystical intro
video with it Impala and it took Lisa
cruisin around the block that's cool
what frame you're getting ration what
where can they find the movie when it
comes out on one web page
Kilroy the movie on Facebook Kilroy the
movie on Facebook that was the K people
kil Instagram I know that we follow each
other Instagram our actor underscore no
yeah actor underscore Wilson underscore
by meters thank you for where will you
find you at P Espinosa P Espinoza man
how are you man how are ya back thanks
for being on our show man I think about
the whole way when it comes out what
stop illegal
chili dog alright looking forward to
shock collar down right on all right
fool oh yeah my bike